more terrifying reality is that all all
the all the reporters that we've talked
to who've covered this said it's mostly
young women being raped by the human
traffickers we are the freest country in
the world I mean anyone who comes from
any other country any any immigrant to
Finland makes it less white any
immigrant to America makes it less free
we are shockingly the freest country in
the world in so many ways that other
cultures do not understand the rape
cultures around the country are going to
be quite a surprise for the feminists I
mean let me just tell you ladies you
never had it so good do you know that
rapes in Britain in Germany in Sweden
rapes are off the charts women are
afraid to walk alone in big cities
because they have imported these people
they have different views as it's as it
relates to women and minorities and
everything else